[Music]
you're probably wondering how did i do
that
[Music]
[Laughter]
music is a story about life and it's a
story about heart
nobody wants to hear c sharp major with
a sharp eleventh
all these technical things that's not
music that's craft
if it's devoid of the heart then it
doesn't mean anything
we're going to talk about harmony melody
more importantly
looking at one's own ability to develop
one's own sound
if there's something that you feel at
the moment that's how i wrote
watermelon man the women they would be
saying hey
watermelon man and that's how i came up
with
[Music]
if we take the blues
i did a turn on that you see that
because you can't bend notes on the
piano so it's an attempt to make it
sound kind of
guitar-like instead of bending them we
just go back and forth between them
working with miles davis where i played
something that was
technically wrong i thought i had just
destroyed
everything miles played some notes and
he made my
chord right i judged what i had played
miles didn't
that's what every jazz musician should
do
[Music]
the problem happens when you don't put
that first snow down
just start
believe that you can be better than
where you are right now i mean that's
all i have
i hope i can be better tomorrow than i
am today
i'm herbie hancock this is my master
[Music]
class
you